bien problema número 17 dice alma y
camila están sentadas espalda con
espalda y ellas caminan 10 pasos en
direcciones opuestas la una a la otra y
para ok imagínate que aquí está el
cambio de color aquí esta alma y aquí
está a camila a espalda con espalda y
van a caminar diez pasos entonces para
acá para caminar diez pasos camila en
dirección contraria a lo que va
caminando para cada alma y son diez
pasos diez pasos ok
alma se dé la vuelta y camina hasta
llegar a camila en un total de 17 de sus
pasos o que yo creo que haber aquí están
alma y camila y hasta acá va a llegar
alma ok ya está está va allegar camila
pero alma va a caminar diez de sus pasos
es decir que la distancia que hay de que
acá son diez veces los pasos del alma y
de igual manera para camila caminaba a
caminar diez pasos pero diez de sus
pasos es decir de los pasos de camila ok
después llegamos a que alma está a gusto
aquí 'la maestra' justo aquí se voltean
ve acá milán y va a caminar rumbo a
camila va a caminar hasta llegar a
caminar pero no hace en 17 de sus pasos
lo hace en 17 de sus pasos de los pasos
de alma ok hasta llegar a camila justo
aquí está camino perfecto que es lo que
nos preguntan lo que necesitamos saber
es la longitud de uno de los pasos del
alma en términos de los pasos de caminar
porque es que fíjate bien si alma camina
hasta acá hasta acá hasta ver a camila
hasta acá hasta acá sabemos que ella ha
recorrido diez de sus pasos hasta lleva
10 los pasos de alma porque porque si
recorre 10 pasos hacia la izquierda y
después de recorrer los mismos s la
derecha llegaría al punto donde hicieron
que era justo aquí y después de caminar
de aquí destacan 7 más de sus pasos 7 de
los pasos de alma es decir que alma
tiene una zancada o caminar con una
longitud mayor a comparación de la
zancada o de los pasos de camila y justo
aquí ya podemos ver una igualdad estamos
diciendo que 10 veces o 10 de los pasos
de camila es exactamente igual a 7 de
los pasos de alma y lo que nos preguntan
es cuál es la longitud de uno de los
pasos de alma es decir lo que queremos
es despejar la a de aquí a en términos
de los pasos de camila y fíjate bien que
no sabemos qué tan largo son sus pasos
lo que sabemos es este vuelta de aquí
que diez pasos de camila son igual a
siete pasos de alma y si de aquí
queremos despejar a amd me va a quedar
que es igual a 10 cm
a éste dice que tengo aquí entre 711 que
pase fue dividirlos de 7 o multiplique
todo por un séptimo y ya está
10 en 37 es la respuesta de este
problema los pasos de alma es igual a 10
veces los pasos de camila entre 7 y
vamos a resolver el último problema dice
problema número 18 ponemos aquí el
problema número 17 y problemas número 18
espera déjenme ser otra capa problema
número 18 dice si
fx si excede x es igual a equis cuadrada
más 18 ok y tenemos un número m positivo
m es positivo en el medio que 0 tal que
se cumple que efe de 2m es igual a 2
veces
fm ok entonces cuánto vale m
perfecto pues a qué te parece si
utilizamos la definición de esta función
que es f de 2m bueno pues efe de 12 m lo
que hay que hacer es sustituir en esta
función a 12 m cada vez que veamos x es
decir que voy a tener a 2 m elevado al
cuadrado más 18 esto utilizando la
definición de esta función esto tiene
que ser igual a dos veces a dos veces
este de m pero tienes fm bueno pues lo
que hay que hacer es sustituir a x por m
en esta función me va a quedar a 2 que
multiplicar a m cuadrada más 18 y ten
cuidado este 2 multiplica a todo efe tm
ok pues de aquí lo que se despejará m me
va a quedar que cuatro veces m cuadrada
más 18 es igual a 2 m cuadrada más 18
por dos es 36 ok y si de aquí paso este
para acá y este para gam que me va a
quedar
cuadrada - 2 m cuadrada es exactamente
lo mismo que 36 menos 18 ok ya casi
tengo la solución dos veces m cuadrada
es igual a 18 ok 4 m cuadrada menos 2 m
cuadrada es 2 m cuadrada y de aquí puedo
decir que m cuadrada
de aquí sigue esto de can es igual a 18
entre 2 se multiplicó todo por un medio
y por ciento encuadrada es igual a 9 y
de aquí voy a sacar raíz de ambos lados
de la ecuación así que tenemos la raíz
de este lado y la raíz de este lado me
va a quedar que m es igual a más
menos 3 ojo recuerda que cuando sacamos
la raíz cuadrada a un número obtenemos
un resultado positivo y un resultado
negativo hasta aquí podemos decir que es
igual a más menos 3 pero lo que me piden
es que me sea positiva es justo una de
mis hipótesis
este problema me dicen si m es un número
positivo tal que se cumpla todo esto
entonces no me puedo tomar a m con un -3
necesita ser forzosamente positivo
entonces la solución de este problema es
que m sea igual a 3 a 3 positivo y esta
es la solución del problema en mi igual
a 3 es un número positivo tal que se
cumpla que f de 12 m sea igual a 2 veces
efe dm y ya está aquí la respuesta de
este problema número 18 lo hemos logrado
así que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo
donde vamos a empezar una nueva sección
hasta la próxima